and there's some news uh just coming out  of this meeting between  joe biden and boris johnson and uh one  line is that the uk and the us  have agreed a new partnership to fight  future  uh pandemics and to tackle health  inequalities the uk government has also  confirmed launch of a new center for  pandemic preparedness  which will spearhead it says the uk's  work to develop a global early warning  system  to detect new infectious disease  threats and  and there's also the uk us partnership  will be formed for  a brand new pathogen surveillance  network to help save lives and protect  health systems by spotting diseases  before they spread so that's coming out  of the meeting between joe biden boris  johnson  in cornwall